[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est beau tu es beau ça pour vous
c'est bon c'est magnifique
[Rires]
comment ça va très bien oui et alors
comme les absents ont toujours tort je
vais en mettre plein la tranchéta à
Matthieu Delormeau alors il devait être
là et comme par hasard il nous a fait un
mytho ouais j'ai pas pu parce que j'ai
eu un truc vous inquiétez pas il va en
prendre pour son goût pendant plusieurs
jours
pourquoi du comment j'avais l'impression
que l'ambiance était un petit peu
électrique avec Cyril en ce moment non
pas vous vous trouvez pas regarde tu vas
venir à côté de moi
attention
[Musique]
avec Mathieu Delormeau réponse a lui
faire le bonjour de la pieuvre réponse B
lui proposer un weekend à Mykonos
lui proposait d'être de la doublure de
Béatrice Rosen dans le prochain Batman
réponse d la guichet avec son torse velu
la réponse
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes contents d'avoir Benjamin
Castaldi dans l'équipe de TPMP
[Rires]
l'élocution l'élocution c'est vrai mais
aussi c'est vrai qu'il a une expérience
avec lui une expérience de la télévision
mais si on vous écoute avec Mathieu
pendant la pub il n'y a que ça
une personne symbole de la symbole alors
si autant serrer la team vous allez voir
que Matthieu Delormeau c'est toujours
un jeu du monde regardez comme il est
assume
[Applaudissements]
en parlant de Benjamin Castaldi si vous
voulez faire un peu d'économie Cyril
bien j'ai un petit conseil pour vous
vous devriez peut-être le payer au mot
prononcé
gagnerez beaucoup d'argent
[Rires]
pas spécialement
[Musique]
de l'argent
je t'ai parlées et vapoter c'est pas bon
sportif pas besoin de ça
j'ai pas vu
cette semaine c'était le moment de
retrouvailles avec votre ami Fabrice dit
vite on a laissé une caméra sur vous
Cyril parce que quand Fabrice des visuel
est là dans ce mot en France 3 1980 vous
adorez faire le pitre
[Rires]
simplement
pas argumenté à l'instant le vaccin
sauvait des gens maintenant il sauve des
pays pourquoi la lune
c'est que ça fait effectivement
maintenant excusez-moi il faut lire
autre chose que Picsou Magazine
[Applaudissements]
en interrupteur
mais toi tu ne sais toujours rien après
les
[Applaudissements]
religion
je l'adore je suis fan de Fabrice
division est-ce que vous savez ce que ce
document alors pour vous à la maison
j'explique c'est un conducteur c'est un
conducteur c'est un document sur lequel
toutes les séquences d'une émission sont
indiquées et bien Cyril vous savez qu'il
est le producteur de TPMP mais également
de TPMP people avec Mathieu Delormeau
sauf que Cyril vous savez il aime bien
piéger il aime bien prendre OK et il a
voulu piéger Mathieu en annonçant à
l'antenne toutes les séquences mais que
Matthieu Delormeau allait faire dans sa
propre émission regardez bien la tête de
Mathieu il était en décomposition finale
ça c'était bien on va se retrouver dans
un instant avec un gros sommaire dans un
instant Céline Dion pas fan de sa
belle-fille Pamela Anderson sur sa
biographie novatia balance sur les
nouveaux télécrossiers on aura Smain
avec nous dans un instant également et
j'ai retrouvé l'anonymat après avoir été
connu c'est le programme qui vous attend
dans touche pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est le conducteur
aujourd'hui et bien vous savez vous
mettez votre argent Cyril non dites-moi
parce que en plus de prendre sa pige de
chroniqueur figurez-vous que Mathieu
Delormeau vient ici pour chiner et
prendre des numéros quoi et ça est-ce
que vous trouvez ça normal c'est
horrible
non il est bien après vraiment
[Applaudissements]
la tenue est folle
j'ai envie de le tester enfin
chroniqueur
sinon vous avez déjà le début du numéro
voilà tu as d'autres choses oui bien sûr
vous savez que parfois même souvent vous
allez me dire les membres du public sont
plus actifs que les chroniqueurs en
plateau c'est pas difficile mais la
seule émission à voir ça
et bien l'indique a les yeux partout et
on a voulu me sucer une caméra sur le
public regardez bien cette demoiselle
dans le public c'est la personne la plus
investie de l'histoire des émissions
télé dans le public regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
final c'est une vidéo qui qui conforme à
ma modestie naturelle d'accord vous êtes
content d'être revenu vous avez une
petite amnésie
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore en plus elle est magnifique
merci ma chérie d'être là merci trop
fort
cette semaine on a reçu un agent secret
dans l'émission et vous avez eu un fou
rire à l'antenne sauf que les
téléspectateurs n'ont pas compris
pourquoi vous avez eu un forêt à
l'antenne vous l'avez pas expliqué c'est
vrai oui mais pourquoi moi je suis payé
pour vous montrer pourquoi le pourquoi
il commence bien sûr regardez est-ce que
ça peut arriver ça à Paris ou dans des
grandes villes de France qu'on élimine à
voilà un ennemi en piégeant sa voiture
en plein en plein centre-ville c'était
pas pour les lumineux c'est pour
remonter un parasite qui était qui était
on sait pas où il était justement on
essayait de trop de tirer des ficelles
pour monter à lui d'accord mais pourquoi
sourire et bien la raison de se fourrer
s'appelle Sophie Coste et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi merci
[Rires]
elle m'attrape la pub j'ai une question
à poser
je vais poser cette question et un
moment elle prend la parole
[Rires]
elle est capable
vous êtes très avare en compliment mais
en ce moment je ne sais pas ce qui vous
arrive la preuve en début de chronique
on l'avait fait vous en faites beaucoup
mais sont-ils tous sincères à votre avis
il est compléments tirés sont-ils
Toussains
alors tu es beau tu es beau vous dites
ça des gens que vous n'avez même pas vu
alors que pourtant les invités eux l'ont
bien vu
avec sa famille royale
face à une telle coupe à proximative
mais regardez bien la tête de Cyril
quand il regarde Bertrand Deckers pour
la première fois
pareil
pour la cité au couronnement de Charles
Troyes sont Mégane Bertrand Descartes ce
soir
tu dormais bah non je descends du train
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est incroyable
je l'adore ce mec
j'adore ce mec franchement il est
incroyable je voudrais dire il y a Libye
deux points c'est incroyable avec toutes
les frérots on voit les voir sortez que
la coupe en tout cas pour Bertrand avant
de repartir j'ai une question pour
Jean-Marie est-ce que vous avez déjà
pris une giclée en pleine tête
Jean-Marie une giclée de quoi
très bonne question à laquelle je vais
vous répondre cette semaine il y a eu un
paquet de farine sur le plateau alors
assez bizarrement il est passé entre les
mains de Cyril normalement qui dit
paquet de farine maintes Cyril dit
normalement accident pourtant à
l'antenne pas d'accident tout s'est très
bien passé en antenne c'est autre chose
mais que va bien faire Cyril avec ce
paquet de farine à votre avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on termine avec le vent de la semaine
cinéma
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça me rappelle la semaine
et donc le vent de la semaine
regardez-moi ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]